[Musica]
oggi dovremmo scappare da lo vedete
l'ing dovremo scappare dalla scuole di
boldi o no dice di sé benvenuti nella
mia scuola
rispondi a queste tre domande
velocemente ok ok 2004 05 06 arrabbiato
mi arrabbierò sempre di più mi votate
dai una risposta sbagliata se non avesse
dobbiamo scappare se cinque studenti
carriera la sua età ma io sono baldi
come sei balti positive chiede chi è
quanto è stato raccolto da qui il video
di bardi great to see stata catturata
devi aspettare due minuti oppure essere
liberata dalla chiave
il direttore della scuola è catturato
un'altra persona
la prossima volta poiché io maroni come
all'inizio troppo che mi accade pulizia
in questa classe adesso che mi piace se
questa minoranza e 10 mila mi piace
giocheremo nuovamente abalti qualcuno ha
preso un altro quadro si manca un saluto
quaderni per vincere invece abita ne
mancano solo due studenti ma ho fatto un
fortino di sedie altro aiuto devo
trovare due notebook e abbiamo vinto una
sala mensa forse ma vi siete liberando
tutti devo sbrigarmi trovare altri noti
ma quello di modica paura research
associate ma conte per liberare gli
studenti catturati da boldi ha depresso
che c'è un lupo di avvenuto scattano gli
altri notebook non me lo ricordavo così
grande baldi cioè non mi ricordavo che
la scuola di baldi fosse così grande ma
[Musica]
d'armi nomi aumento che faceva scappare
finché sei tempo ora riesce finché
ancora possibile avete visto baldi dove
l'uscita di torino ci sono qui no
poverino ho preso qualcuno non vediamo
forse sta scadendo il tempo cosa
riuscita a sto giro 2 stato terzo salto
quarto tanto quinto salto ma che faccia
cattiva con scopa addio addio mio gol di
[Musica]
baldi ha aperto un cuore e catturato sei
persone però non ha il vinto invece
inizia un altro round e speriamo voglio
essere io bara per vedere com'è tre
baldi iniziando vediamo se sono bondi ma
che ieri sono di maio ballet e compal di
allora dobbiamo rispondere alle domande
prima io non sono banking a fondo stiamo
fermi
ok proponiamo le nostre forze e
cerchiamo amici laggiù a rispondere alle
domande nuovamente bravo
io sto cercando di prenderne uno anche
vitale bukhara ottimo mettiamo in
punizione pro ok sono riusciti a
scappare
ora vado a cercare gli altri quaderni
vediamo vi darete figlio di basico abiti
io lo sento nomadi mi ha vista vediamo
se riesco a prendere questo notebook
io sono qui con baldi hanno potuto aiuto
a tentare di scappare tuttofare gli
atomi fatte vengano qui non c'è del
libro
non ho preso in mano la chiave posta mi
sono liberata perché mi sono bloccato
invece però verso la chiave
ma lasciamo una partita banditi è arreso
sono troppo forte
sabatini abbiamo vinto non abbiamo avuto
noi non siamo riusciti a scappare però
abbiamo preso il libro è un mio problema
io dove sono nei banchi non ci sono
proprio andare a prendere riga da
gigante iniziamo a cercare vitale no no
perché farlo ce ne sono che no questo è
mio figlio è quello è un altro cattivo
biolé o non li se qualcuno sarà vitale
che poi li troverai mai nessuno vado
anche te se però non è solo scappare
avanti
ho fatto bene a scappare 9 giu forza
senza prendere in vita è carico a a
mentre le signore guardi io dove mi
porta arrivato o no hanno già preso due
paderni devo sbrigarmi a prendere più
studenti possibile così riuscito a
scappare quasi sono io il miglior
insegnante di matematica
questa è dire invece della scuola che
punirà chi fa problemi e questa è quella
che ti fa saltare la cosa da e questo è
il bullo della scuola troppo grande
questa scuola persone tutti non me li
aspettavo ma è difficile essere balsi di
tale stato di barasso
andiamo subito a prendere di nuovo gli
altri studenti maker solo giura che
riusciamo a sconfiggere la vita non ho
più veloce perché ho montato quella
sorta di cosa approfittiamone per
cercare tanti tavoletta di cioccolato o
no ora anche tu sei più veloce
per giocare o no mi manca mauro site
fuori dovete dove vedo perché non trova
nessuna è corretto di mezzo a parte che
si devia trovi andare le cose si mettono
andare o no hanno raccolto sette libri o
quindi restano pronti a scappare dove è
uscito un po uno studente scappa vini
solo noi due che c'è
vediamo i risultati trovo catturato tre
studenti però perso la ragazza è l'unica
che riusciti a uscire anche un mese 5
quaderni lasciate in vendita se volete
rivedere basi sul canale è stato super
divertente sette mariti essere baldi per
me la cosa più divertente era essere
baldi a sinistra e poi cliccare per
vedere i nostri alti diano cliccate su
quella che preferite da navigare
ciao